was your father supportive at all or was
he like why don't you become a preacher
or yeah he
what first of all he wanted me to be a
preacher right
and you can imagine when i got to do the
preaching coming to america
i wished my dad was here you know
because is that an impression of your
father
is that an impression of your father a
little bit
a little bit is him and a little bit is
this preacher in chicago
that i saw and this guy he would take
one word and do a whole sermon as a
matter of fact i stole
the whole sermon because he would do he
would say today
my sermon is on the word joy and for an
hour
he talked about joy and he'd get to the
end i got joy
in my leg i got joy in my soul i
it and he would he would and he would go
off and
i actually used the word joy do you feel
joy
say joy joy
and he would put songs you know if
loving the lord is wrong
i don't want to be right and that kind
of stuff
and my dad would do that because he
would try to reach the kids and and
and be aware of pop culture so he could
say something in this sermon that would
get them you know
yeah and there's a certain cadence with
those preachers
that it's that breathing thing it's like
you do it i you do it naturally i i
can't do it
now everybody in my family is a preacher
so like like i have
ladies my aunt is a preacher my uncle i
have uncles and could they all
it's the family yeah yeah
and i have an uncle who his his hook is
he'll he'll do this thing
the lord came down and walked he put
that in the middle of everything
down the road he said lord lord
you know what that thing is but he does
it
and did you ever sit down did you ever
sit down with him and go what the [ __ ]
is
my dad would do this thing where you say
moses
came down the mountain
[Music]
and i was like that's some al green [ __ ]
you doing right there but he would do
things like that
that would blow me away and and and the
ladies
my dad the ladies would go crazy in the
church
you know reverend hall that he preaching
did your father
get to see your success and see did you
get to say hey
look at me now he had gotten to see me
on tv as a magician once
because um when i was little they flew
me to new york
to do a show called soul and i think
they just did a documentary on that show
this gentleman who uh who had a show in
new york and they flew me there to do
magic
and my dad got to announce at the end of
church one sunday
uh watch my son tonight he'll be doing
magic
on television you know that was kind of
cool